لن يصل المركب الى اي مكان قبل تخفيف
حمولته الزائده ربما يلخص هذا المفهوم ما
قامت به شركات التكنولوجيا العملاقه خلال
الاسابيع الاخيره من موجات تسريح بالالاف
طالت موظفين وحتى المتعاقدين لكن لا يمكن
فهم هذا الفعل دون دراسه ما حدث في عامين
غلب عليهما كورونا وتاثيره على سلوك الناس
والشركات فجاه وجد قطاع التكنولوجيا نفسه
في بؤره الاهتمام والتركيز مع الاغلاقات
التي عمت العالم وابقت الموظفين والطلاب
في منازلهم
حينها تضاعف الطلب على اجهزه الكمبيوتر
المحمول لتلبيه معايير العمل عن بعد تضاعف
معه حجم التسوق عبر الانترنت مع توقف في
اغلب المحل عن استقبال الزبائن حتى
التسليه اغلقت الملاعب والحدائق ليصبح
الميدان الوحيد المتاح العاب الفيديو
والافلام
لذا حين تضاعف كل هذا كان لابد لعدد
العاملين في هذه الشركات
ايواكب الزياده لكن الان انتهت الاغلاقات
وعدت الامور الى طبيعتها لتفكر الشركات في
التاقلمي مع وضعها الجديد فما عوده الحياه
الى طبيعتها وتراجع الارادات كان لابد من
التخلص من الحمل الزائد لكن ازمتين اخرين
ظهرت في الصوره
الاولى هي التضخم واتجاه اغلب الدول لرفع
اسعار الفائده
والثانيه والتي تعد نتيجه للاولى وهي
الركود التي بدات مؤشراته في الظهور
بمختلف الاسواق
50 الف موظفين دفعوا ثمن ما حدث خاصه في
شركات عمالقه التكنولوجيا امازون وجوجل
ومايكروسوفت وميتا لكن الاخطر ان هذه
الارقام حدثت بينما لم يدخل الاقتصاد
العالمي مرحله الركود فقط ترك الباب جاسم
محسن العربيه